we are joined by uh uh one of our
favorite guests
and uh he was calling the game with iron
eagle on yes he's one of the
broadcasters for brooklyn nets games you
also see him
on the worldwide leader in sports an
espn long time nba player now
turned broadcaster richard jefferson how
are you richard
i am outstanding how are you guys doing
today i am doing fine
uh what do you make of last night's game
with the nets richard jefferson
you go for it uh one what i make of
the cleveland cavaliers actually have a
pretty strong team
uh no what i make from it there's so
much there's so many layers to it one
uh you know to see kyrie and kd and
james harden play
you know close to 50 minutes last night
i think was
encouraging because one james harden is
not in the best condition
you know are not in his championship
normal condition uh
kyrie was missing two weeks and you know
kd's coming back from an achilles so
you know to see these guys be able to
play the way they did
uh it was encouraging i i think you know
they are going to be a talented team but
i think the deficiencies in their team
whether it's the size uh whether it's
uh you know individual team defense um
they have a lot of firepower but they
also have some spots that they need to
shore up but when they do
literally to me it's them and the lakers
like
i'm sorry but those are the only two
teams that i really feel
have all of the things necessary to be
you know a powerhouse
all right let's use that uh that opening
salvo from you
um as the launching off point because
you said a lot right there let's start
you talked about hard getting into shape
did he lose 30 pounds in 20
20 hours just by being acquired by the
nuts richard
i i don't know i you know what's so
weird is all of the pictures of him
all of the pictures of him um
that looked like he was heavier were all
like in warm-ups and i'm not saying that
he was wearing a few extra tops or maybe
a back wrap or whatever
uh but it seems like there was a level
of embellishment there
i don't you know i i look nba players
are
are you know physical specimens but i
don't think you could lose that much
weight
but that being said when you're playing
46 minutes a night
all you got to do is mix in a couple of
salads and you know not
you know eating unhealthy and the stuff
will fall off of you very very quickly
especially when you're in the prime of
your career so
you know if he it has refocused himself
if he's re-locked in if he's doing the
things that he needs
to become the the mvp caliber
james harden that he's been for the last
five seasons i imagine that flipping a
switch you could see a body change in a
matter of ten days in two weeks so
you're saying he was wearing like
he was wearing a clump suit warming up
or something like that
minus the head piece minus the head
makeup okay
yeah so i'm just wondering if yeah i
think that's what he was rocking
yeah i'm just because again he's
he definitely seems much happier and
better
and and certainly but rich rich rich we
can't trust the internet you know you
can't trust the internet you see a
couple of pictures and you're just like
oh is that real is that embellished you
know at the end of the day he showed
that he showed up
and he's had three triple doubles in
four games
and he's had two 30-point triple doubles
so
you know say whatever you want like he's
getting into better shape
but those numbers are monstrous like i'm
not going to talk about a physical shape
i want to talk about his physical
numbers
and his numbers look great thus far
richard jefferson here on the rich eisen
show you also
uh referred to kyrie being away for two
weeks
what can you tell me what do you know
what can you share about why he was away
for him being away at all richard
what happened there there's just there
there hasn't been much you know
clarification has been much
communication
you know i think you know you
professional sports as you guys know is
one of those things where it's like
you don't really get a break you know
it's like you have your off season and
when you're in season you're expected to
be on
24 hours a day seven days a week right i
used to joke and tell people that we
didn't i don't know
what day of the week it is because our
days of the week go travel day
practice day game day off day like
that's all we have there is no monday
tuesday wednesday
and so i think you know whatever it was
that there were things going on in his
personal life that he needed to address
if there were things that were going on
you know maybe with a family member that
he needed to address and he needed some
time away just for
you know whether it's mental or
emotional clarity that's fine but i will
say this he did play for two weeks
and that man went out and he scored what
38 last night and played
46 minutes so as much as we want to
criticize him for needing that time away
and a lack of communication i think that
was a big part a lack of communication
he was in very good shape he was still
working out he didn't just like i'm
gonna go to the bahamas and like eat and
drink and like take my time off and i
need time
no you know he was working out he was
doing the things that were necessary for
him
to show back up to his team and be
effective so as far as i'm concerned
this was a personal matter he needed to
time off he needed to do a better job of
communicating
very very early to his team not to the
media not to the fans to his team
that's the part that added a lot of
skepticism to what was going on and then
there was obviously other issues but
that was the part that i think he
recognized that he needed to do a better
job but to his credit
he was in shape and he didn't just take
time off well i
and and here's the thing because again i
i don't i don't know him
i've never really met him richard so i'm
and i'm not one of those types to sit in
a chair like this in front of a
microphone like this and a platform like
this and just
just fire away because i didn't like his
body language in a zoom
you know uh but i i the the question i
do have and maybe you can help me here
is he does seem like a very
conscientious
thinker of a player who has
a platform that he thought uh he should
uh give up because
uh the social injustice going on in this
country
in his mind was more important for him
to pay attention to
and throw all of his energies in rather
than go to a bubble which obviously he
wasn't gonna
go to anyway but my point is this is
if there is something that was going on
even if it was a private matter even if
it was a problem to use his platform to
tell people hey
this is the stuff that athletes go
through and we know this is what i'm
going i go through something similar
you two and maybe use this platform to
communicate that
to even fans who definitely want to know
um
does this guy you know care for me to
invest myself
into watching a game like last night
like that's the issue
and i agree i agree and it's weird
because it's like
i've expressed this to people kyrie and
i know this is going to sound probably
not
nobody owes anything to anybody i know
that sounds very selfish and i know the
fans
you like well the fans support you and
the fans watch you and the fans do this
and the fans do that
that is true but if kyrie were to retire
tomorrow
he doesn't owe an explanation he kyrie
could disappear kevin durant could
disappear we've seen it from guys like
barry sanders calvin johnson guys in the
prime of their career
i just want to move on and so you know
for kyrie
the people that matter most and why i
think there was such
there was a fair amount of criticism on
him it was because
the lack of communication with his team
now when he came back he addressed the
team he addressed the people that
mattered within the organization because
i stand this
he needs to you you say like oh well he
needs to address this with the fans and
it's like well look
the net could trade him tomorrow and
do he does he have to address the fans
then do the team have to address the
nets fans that loved kyrie
no they say thank you thank you kyrie
for your service move on
right and this is for a player that's
well behaved and perfect they can still
just say
what move on so the only thing that that
really and truly matters is that the
people
in the locker room understand that kyrie
is there that he's locked in that he's
focused on the final goal
and for this team it should be winning a
championship i agree
that like you do oh like there's a
mentality that you owe fans
but ultimately the only people that
truly matter when you're
on this journey are the people within
the locker room don't be disrespectful
now if you don't like him don't watch
the games
if you don't like him don't buy his
shoes if you don't like him don't don't
don't buy his jersey
you know that's one thing you have the
right as a consumer to not do that but
to say that like
i need personal time off and i owe it to
fans to address that
i feel like that's a misconception
richard jefferson espn nba analyst and
yes
network brooklyn nets analyst and
long-time
veteran of the nba here on the rich
eisen show you also said see i'm not
lying
but from your opening statement i'm
going to pull on the strings here
you also said that there are some
weaknesses that that when they shore up
look out how do they short out what
needs to be
shored up and how how do they do it
since it seems that
uh they're out of draft capital to cough
up and any sort of uh deadline
deal or or or this is the unit that
they're going to have
walk me through that richard well and
again i don't think it's championship or
bus
i think this team has the talent that
you know they're they're
you know them and the lakers probably
have the most talent and the most
whatever
when you look at like how do you win and
how do you compete
um i really and truly look at uh you
know
the net and like their lack of size
deandre jordan played well and he's
playing he's playing better but losing
jared allen was big so now you have
deandre jordan he's your one true
big and now they've bumped people up but
now when you're talking about team
defense
they need to be between 10 and 15.
they're probably not going to be at the
top 10
defense because they don't have the debt
but they if they hover around 13 they're
first in field goal percentage
which is amazing because they have
perimeter shooters right kd
kyrie james harden are perimeter
shooters but they're highly efficient
perimeter shooters
and then they're third in i think their
third and points per game but they're
they're like 16th in turnovers
you can't turn the ball over if you're
not going to be a great defensive team
if you're
if you're the 18th ranked defensive team
and you're
20 seconds in turnovers it doesn't
matter how great your offense is
you're giving the other team easy
buckets and easy extra opportunities
so they got to lower their turnover they
need to be again
as long as they stay within the middle
as long as they're 10 11 12
in the league in turnovers 10 11 12 13
in defense
now their offensive efficiency goes
through the roof and so
those are the areas and i think you know
they do need to find some depth they do
need to figure it out and i know there's
different trades and there's other guys
his names are probably going to be
mentioned there's going to be buyouts
for players late and if you're a guy
let's say hypothetically like a pj
tucker i'm not saying that this happened
but a name like that that gets bought
out or traded in waves
you know who like the nets are going to
be the number one
team for those veterans that are bought
out at the end because
lakers are loaded clippers are loaded do
you want to go to milwaukee
you know miami's got a ton of young
teams there's philly i think is good
boston's loaded brooklyn is the one team
that you could look at it's like
there is an opportunity to play and win
a championship
if i get waived by whatever team i can
go sign with them for the veteran
minimum for this year
and go contribute to what they're doing
that's when things start to get scary
hit me with the eastern conference team
that uh that could derail this
championship run give me one for you you
know
they played against milwaukee and i just
still don't think milwaukee has enough
right you look at the late game when
they beat milwaukee it's like chris
middleton was the individual that was
taking the last two shots
for their team and you know giannis had
a very good game
but you know but ultimately i think you
know there's boston they're silly
the milwaukee is the same normal
characters but i really think that the
nets
are really one or two pieces you know a
little bit more
defense cleaning up their turnover
situation from
really if they're healthy they have too
much firepower for almost every single
team
philly could be a problem with their
size to buy his hair is joel and b
the joel embiid is playing and he's
banging
and and posting up extremely well
against deandre jordan
there's nobody else to come in after
deandre jordan right there's nobody else
to come in so if deandre jordan's in
foul trouble
joel embiid could really cause a problem
for that team
including ben simmons with his size it's
just a matter of whether or not they can
score enough points to keep up with the
net
but the size of philly could be a
problem but it's really the nets to lose
and and they still have areas that they
can improve in my opinion how's nash
handling all this
in your estimation
i know what a first rodeo here you want
to coach we're going to give you the
most
loaded team of all time and there's
going to be a lot of stuff going on
i think steve yeah i think you know what
i think really helps i think having dan
tony there
helps because d'antoni had a
relationship with
you know it's hard right like james
harden won an mvp with him
um so having having jack vaughn who was
there
with kevin durant and kev and and kyrie
last year
having having steve nasa had a
relationship with kevin durant
i think this group especially especially
katie and kyrie
you need to connect with them on a human
level not just on a basketball level
right i don't think they're the players
that show up play basketball go home
right like they need more than just like
a basketball coach they need a person
that they
believe believes in them on all aspects
of their life and so i think steve nash
is a perfect guy for that and including
you know you got imeidoka you have a
great
balanced staff there with the nets that
i think
helps it's not just steve nash as a
first time head coach
and there's no relationships up and down
that that
uh that staff with the players they all
there's relationships
with uh just riddled within and then i
guess
like uh to finish up here uh richard
you've when i first asked you
what do you make of last night's game
you say the cavs have a good team you
know well let's
i know they don't have uh harden and
kyrie
and durant which is why we're finally
getting around to the team that actually
won
last night we're also we're also on on
the radio in the great state of ohio
um and last night i guess if it was a
bowl game it would have been the richard
jefferson bowl
uh since you uh have some some cavs ties
connections to both
exactly so what do you mean you know i
love sex then and they they're not even
all they didn't have kevin love
they didn't have darius garland uh but
colin sexton is such a competitor you
look at like he had blocked shots he was
playing defense he was making plays he
was distributing
to score 20 points in a row like dude
like
there's prime players there are players
in their prime great
mvp players that have not done that uh
and so
you know he's a very very talented young
guard i think he's getting better i
still think he needs to learn how to get
his teammates involved just to smidge
more and i know i'm being critical for a
kid that's averaging 25 points a game
but that raises your team's level uh i
think jb bickerstaff has done an amazing
job
he's finally got an opportunity to coach
you know he's been
an interim head coach in houston interim
head coach and a head coach for one year
in memphis
he just never really got the opportunity
to have a team
a training camp and like two or three
years of working and developing with
talent
and i think this is a great opportunity
i think jb bickerstaff is going to be a
great coach i know
you want to say young because he's only
like 41 but he's
a great young head coach that's been in
the game for
20 plus years and what about drummond
allen had more minutes last night are
they
is that somebody that they're kicking
the tires on to see if drummond uh
who's gonna have to get paid needs to be
moved what do you think of that
situation yeah drummond drummond is so
good leading the league and rebounding
he's just so
talented and such a big force um you
know i think
jared allen is probably you know uh a
a fail-safe because it's like hey jared
allen is a very very good big he's not
probably going to get the the drummond
numbers right but if you were to
trade drummond for pieces or draft picks
you have a very good young big that
should have been starting for the nets a
lot of people believe
um you you have a very young baby that
you can you know pay
probably half the price but he's got a
ton of potential one of the best shot
blockers in the league
so that gives you the leverage to to
maybe trade drummond to
get some pieces maybe get some more
young talent especially with kevin
porter
uh you know struggling you know with
some things there so you're losing the
wing that everyone thought was going to
be the future 18 19 point a game score
for you
so now you have that option with
drummond and look ultimately if drummond
is going to be a guy that's going to
to be a stud and a star he might have to
do it someplace else and get his money
someplace else i think the pickup of
jared allen was huge
but it also sometimes leads to the
writing on the wall for
a great player like drummond it's like
no you're great no one's questioning
your greatness
it's just we're too young we're not very
good you're probably going to be moved
someplace
uh so that we can you know kind of
restructure it's no different than chris
paul getting traded from oklahoma city
it's not that he's not great it's just
we're not going to continue going in
this direction and we'd be wasting your
greatness right here right now
richard i really appreciate the call man
great i was listening to you and i and
on that broadcast last night and uh him
telling you to go
google uh colin sexton i know he was
jerk right
i was hilarious i am the nervous of this
guy and it was like
dude i'm kind of busy right now i can't
just sit here and google stuff
but you know he doesn't care about that
stuff yeah
he doesn't care he's so funny richard
thanks for the call let's uh let's chat
again soon
thanks brother really appreciate it
thanks richard you bet that's richard
jefferson he's great
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here